yeah but then i mean i never could
actually i'm gonna text him right now
i'm like what's up dog
i don't remember the question that was
asked it's like what do you think about
the fight on june 3rd he goes
i never give up yeah it doesn't matter
how many rounds
i'm in it i don't live to live
i was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about man
oscar de la hoya are you hungry let me
tell you something the chicken or the
egg
oh [ __ ] wrong with this situation all
right well that was
the commentary was so trashed in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
if you are a first time listener uh my
bad uh
this is gonna be a good waste of your
[ __ ] hour of your life
yay here we have we have patrick.t dot
riley
stand up coming back in commission let's
go missing out on a show tonight because
the car exploded and we got nick the
sweaty ear
sweaty i brought some napkins just in
case your boy gets a little
i'm never gonna let you live that down
ever again dude that was one of the
funniest moments of my life and
sometimes i deliver those you know what
i mean and it's uh it may not be
intentional but i may i may
can you can you give us a walk through
of what you were thinking when that
happened because you know what it was
crazy and also what you were feeling too
oh yeah yeah definitely so um
yeah so like if i can go back to my
genius a little bit and just kind of
reminisce about like
how i just you know just delivered a
performance of a lifetime
uh i think it was
a lack of thinking yeah yeah we're all
talking and i was like oh wait
that sounds like something that i really
liked and i really enjoyed
so let me tell you about it and as i was
explaining i realized i go wait
i'm telling this like i'm just talking
to a couple [ __ ] [ __ ] friends of
mine
and i forget that we're on a [ __ ]
podcast and i have to say something
so what's up so when you talk to your
friends you also tell them stories that
go nowhere
yeah what the [ __ ] is that even if you
were talking to your friends hey
what [ __ ] are you talking about i guess
this whole guy hey you've known me long
enough you know i've done this from time
to time
i do from time to time you know halfway
when you were telling that story i i
legit was thinking about whipping out my
phone opening up google maps and say hey
where the [ __ ] are you going
give me the direction that's that's some
good [ __ ] yeah i wasn't going to do that
that's some stand-up comedy [ __ ] i was
zoned out honestly yeah
i was trying i was trying to like i was
trying to like refocus
come back he's talking he's talking he's
your
i was like damn refocus he's your friend
he wouldn't do this to you you wouldn't
love me
he wouldn't let you down like this like
stick in there and then you you
let me and everybody down you know what
and and you know
sometimes you just have to do these
types of things yeah and you never
answered the question what made you
think that that was okay yeah yeah
and that didn't make you think i didn't
in my head i just was like oh yeah just
go for it if we put a thermometer in
your mouth at that moment how hot how
was
seven do you think that about 107.
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it'll be like
the cartoon where it hits the [ __ ]
top
the thermometer would explode yeah it
doesn't go down it would have blown up
but i would have died yeah you would
have died brain damage how many times
has that happened to you um
like recently in the past week just in
general did it happen a lot but you just
think you explode not really no
i think that was too far that was
special circumstances i [ __ ] love you
that was the best out of me i'm sorry
oh you're the best you guys bring it out
of me oh you know who died
oh cool you might be very excited
[Laughter]
and let me see if you guys can catch oh
i know who it is i'mma keep it g
real no he didn't die
that was that was false i think no he
died i got time today cause he didn't
have time today he died apparently
he the kid that would in the video was
like no
he did a video and was like everyone
thought i died i'm i'm still alive
i thought that was like keeping g real
cuz today i got talked
i thought he died i got thomas he didn't
die wait was it so the guy that made the
video that was him because i didn't
really do it like was that just some
other random white dude
well at this moment who [ __ ] knows
right it could be any other [ __ ]
suburban white kid who's kind of hood
and [ __ ]
hold on i'mma keep it g real kid dies
but apparently everybody was saying he
died and then he came out saying oh your
boy's still alive i'm alive i'm alive
imagine looking at the news and being
like you're dead i'm dead
what the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up i go
under the radar i mean this article
seems really
what is it what is it from it's from a
website called inside echo
oh yeah that's a very well renowned
reputable site yeah yeah
reputable let me tell you how long ago
was this story because i remember
hearing about this like a month ago this
is march 25th
2021 bro that's recently baby yeah that
was almost about a month ago yeah that's
literally a month almost
to this day to that to this day with
great sadness a renowned rapper g
real he was a rapper horse he was bro
you telling me like you wouldn't think
that kid was a rapper
i would think he is a rapper right bro
if you're stepping up to a bunch of
dudes
that look like they're gonna [ __ ] you up
and he's like yo i keep being g real
today cuz
no it hasn't been debunked he died he
died at the age of 22 he was shot and
killed in colorado
today i got tom that [ __ ] was one of the
funniest videos i've ever seen in my
life hey below key though when are you
talking this type of [ __ ] to some people
and they're like yo you better walk the
[ __ ] away i'll kill your ass
and then a couple years later he ends up
dead this kid was 95 pounds at most
but he's a little dude he was talking
mad [ __ ] to some dudes that like
looked like they would beat the [ __ ] out
of him who who made the video saying
that it was him then and then it was
something
it was i don't know it was something it
was me i'm not dead
that's one last one that's all i saw so
his name is g real
oh that's his name yeah that's his
rapper name g real i thought it was
illegal r.i.p though
so imma keep it g real so he was
referring to himself
from today i got time viral video was
reportedly shot and killed in colorado
aurora police announced
a homicide investigation monday after
officers found a dead man
with multiple gunshot wounds outside of
a south uh
pirorio street tire store sunday morning
tires because yes fool got shot guy
killed can you believe that [ __ ] you
think
you think his rapper name was g real but
after that whole video he was like
i'm just going to take it adopt it maybe
real now that will probably use the same
line and somebody just shot him in the
face
today i got tom well me too yeah bro you
can't be talking spicy like that all the
time this spicy
can't be talking about you know what i
mean i don't think i've ever
i don't think i've ever squared up on
somebody like like that and then just
walk away afterwards because
he said all that just to walk away yeah
and i think
for my recent memory of that video he's
like dropping em bombs and he's like
talking to some black dudes he's
definitely dropping n bombs
yeah he he right there they're in there
they're scattered throughout they're
peppered in they're pepperoni they're
peppered
it's a little he was like what 15 or 14
years old at the time
yeah he must have been youngest is that
that video there are certain areas
that's a great video people just don't
they don't care if they if they say it
or not and he's probably in the hood and
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
whatever and i bet you this kid strapped
too that's why they didn't say anything
probably
yeah i mean his name is g g-reel his
legal name is
on his license driver's license his mom
what's your full name gary real
oh you g real i can't believe this will
die though man
i wanted to see what he was going to end
up oh yeah did you
thought about that guy ever after that
video everything yeah that sucks that he
died bro
he was gonna be a professor yeah i
guarantee it you don't believe in you
he's he's the guy from the the video
that we talked about the uh when he got
the teacher that got in trouble for
dropping m bombs in class
he was going to be him he was on that
path 100 gonna be him dude yeah
but [ __ ] um we are going to talk
about the uh the boxing match
between uh jake paul and ben askren
one of the most disappointing fights i
only watched
it off as soon as i saw the knockout i
was like [ __ ] this we had to eat our
words because we were we were talking to
ben asked like a mother here's the thing
here's the thing
when the fir when the fight first got
announced we all were saying
jake paul's gonna knock this fool out
right we're all saying that
but as the build-up goes on right you
hear ben askren talking and
you're like you know what yeah he's the
pres
i think everything everything that we
wanted was just wishful thinking
well we wanted it to be true no i think
there was there's some
there's some truth to the fact that like
a real fighter has been he he's proven
that he had a chin in the ufc
right and uh whatever but
and yeah maybe part of it is we wanted
him to win but god damn bro like the
best reaction was dc's reaction when did
you see him
like yeah come on you don't let this boy
do you like that
that's exactly how i felt i was like oh
but you're at work like oh my i cannot i
would i literally
the first thing i said was like what a
[ __ ] idiot yeah but when guys
like when guys are hungry they have a
chip on their shoulder like jake paul
who's like yo i'm
beat this [ __ ] i'm gonna beat him up and
then you get a guy like ben asker and
he's like ah yeah he's just some [ __ ]
[ __ ] kid
that makes a difference like that that
intensity makes a big difference
we also didn't realize how much i
thought ben askren was gonna be similar
a similar size to jack paul
and then jake paul is towering over him
he's like 6-2 ben askren is in he's like
what 5 11 or something but
he was also he fights at welterweight or
ufc well which is 170 and that's 170 him
not cutting yeah because he's fat as
[ __ ] at 170.
yeah and then you have uh jake paul
cutting down to 190
and you could tell because did you see
how [ __ ] fat ben askren was yeah
this is the fattest he's ever been i was
shocked
i was shocked how bad he looked he
looked really shitty yeah cause you know
when i i sent the uh the little the
video clip of him
hitting pads i was like oh he's actually
not as bad he looked all right yeah he
did look all right
strong cross he had a good pull back his
hand i mean he was stiff as [ __ ]
but i assumed he was still playing it up
he was not
yeah bro i mean did you see what he when
he uh rolled under the hook and he
connected with the overhand that sure
was nice it was nice
i didn't see that yeah it was it was
pretty promising it would look promising
for like 15 seconds
and then ben uh jake paul started like
the jab to the body a little bit and
just throw some different looks and
and then he caught him dude he just
stepped in he just stepped in and ben
asked him was like this and he just
didn't even move
he did overhand this like this is what
you don't do
don't pull away and because you got
nowhere else to go
we always talk about that [ __ ] and
tyrone woodley has made a career
on doing that to people he starts
pulling and he's a training partner of
his so
it's it sucks it is what it is i feel
like i was just like it's so
embarrassing it's like
oh no dude multiple he's a [ __ ] world
champion in two fighting organizations
he's an olympian and then he lost to a
[ __ ] youtuber yeah
who only has three quote unquote pro
boxing matches yeah
fighting nobody to be fair though jake
paul can box and it was
boxing like an aspirin i mean i didn't
think it was gonna happen at least
i definitely didn't think it was gonna
happen like that even when jake paul won
i thought even if he finished him it was
gonna take like five or six rounds
i didn't think it was gonna happen like
that yeah um
but [ __ ] dude why ben askren has to be
the
the best meme i saw was uh the dude
jesse pinkman from
from breaking bad yeah and it's like oh
he's gonna stop him
no he looks like he's like it's like
when uh jake paul knocked out ben askren
it's him crying he's like he can't keep
getting away with that
i mean he's he's going to have to fight
a real boxer at this point yeah
because he ain't he he's not why would
he though they're angling for tyrone
woodley right there like there's beef
there
bj penn has to fight him i really hope
bj penn doesn't bro
got knocked out like on a street fight
in hawaii like a year ago there's like a
video of him getting [ __ ] up in a
street fight so he's just too old
please don't put pj pen has to fight his
alcoholism first and then we'll see what
happens after that's true yeah let's
let's get him into [ __ ] a real quick
sorry bj pet but
ding ding baby 12 steps 12 rounds
the first batch we've been losing all
rounds dude
he's getting [ __ ] up like if you're
jake paul bro it's like
he's making so he sold 1.5 million
pay-per-view buys for
fighting ben astro what was up with
oscar de la hoya dude what
that boy is [ __ ] out of his mind brain
oscar de la hoya
was [ __ ] coat the hell out he's
always he's a
bro it's crazy you know he's supposed to
fight him
alvarez they're talking about did you
see his hands though he's still
[ __ ] good yeah i mean he's still i
mean even if he's old he's still got the
skill for sure 100
i was kind of shocked how good he still
was because of all you know he just like
a few months ago he was fat as [ __ ]
yeah but he looks good like he could box
again like riding a bike bro
when you're at that level well also even
like tyson tyson looked good against roy
jones
that's true too tyson looked really nice
when you're at a certain skill level and
you take time off
i gotta find the clip of just oscar de
la hoya not answering a question at all
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] oh he was such
a train wreck he's like i'd never back
down
i'll never quit i'll go down to the end
and you're like all right bro it's like
on food's gone wild it's like
when you're theo at the end of the carne
asada it's like all aggressive and [ __ ]
dog that floor is crazy and if you live
in you know
and you you know you go out at night
sometimes there's a good chance you
might see oscar de la hoya you know
welling out bro everyone's got a g if
you everyone's got a good idea
i have his phone number he gave me his
phone number oh [ __ ] let's call him up
hey oscar what's going on what's up dawg
i couldn't believe it i
met him at a bar uh that was supposed to
be drinking
uh he was we were all drinking uh and
rocco's he gave me no no it was a blind
donkey and he gave me his number and i
was putting it in and i was like i can't
believe i'm
i was like this is [ __ ] crazy yeah
that's tight bro
yeah but then i mean i never connected
i'm gonna text him right now i'm like
what's up dog
i remember the question that was asked
it's like what do you think about the
fight on june 3rd he goes i never
give up yeah it doesn't matter how many
rounds i'm
in it i don't live to live
i was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about man
oscar de la hoya are you hungry let me
tell you something the chicken or the
egg is
xfl just [ __ ] you know what the
crazy thing is
i i dislike snoop dogg a lot i don't
yeah he was kind of he was kind of a bit
much yeah he was too much
yeah at times i don't like him on there
either yeah
because it's like i get it bro you're
trying to be funny but it's also like
these guys are fighting bro like yeah
[ __ ] show
just a little bit more respect just a
little bit and isn't he
isn't he like a shareholder in the
[ __ ] company like doesn't he maybe
he's invested in it and he's like
actively betting against [ __ ]
yeah screaming dude
yeah just screaming bro and it just like
when you watch that and it's like
there was literally it was literally
coachella bro it was coachella and
boxing you know like
half the actually more than half of the
event was
was like musical performances there was
one fight on there
apparently one of the guys who was
fighting was like a singer or like a
music artist his name was like rayquan
or something recon or some [ __ ]
and then he was fighting against a guy
like he has no
professional boxing experience i think
he was like his first fight ever
and he was fighting a guy who had
previous boxing experience this podcast
is brought to you by
better help my friends if you guys know
me you guys know how much i
stress mental health and you guys
specifically taking care of it
now if you haven't thought about better
help or trying online counseling
this might be the one for you they have
counselors that are trained
professionals ready for you
to help you out this might be something
that you feel like you don't need but
trust me we all
need a little bit of help sometimes
there is a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas
the services available for clients
worldwide are there for you you can log
into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone session so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
better help and genius brain listeners
get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius once again that's b e t t e r h
e l p dot com slash genius get the
mental health and help you need my
friends
trust me i've been using it for a long
time and it has been the best thing
that i have ever used in my life give it
a go once again that's betterhelp.com
genius to go ahead and get 10 off your
first month today
and like he looked like a pro like and
you could tell like you when you watch
someone that doesn't know how to spar or
how to box against someone that does
know how to box and he took the fight
he took the fight and he's toying with
him and he eventually dropped them in
like the first or second round
but it was just like why who the [ __ ] is
making these fights
you know but this is the weird thing
right because every there's there's like
two sides to this story and even boxers
are
kind of going with this narrative
they're saying that this might be a good
thing for boxing to get fresh eyes on it
right
but the fresh eyes on this style of
boxing will only last if the fights are
like this
they're not going to watch real boxers
right they're in it to watch
the [ __ ] show they're not there to watch
boxing so
after these these youtubers or whatever
they stop boxing you think they're it's
going to convert the viewership to real
boxing
boxing fans yeah right it's spectacles
circus [ __ ]
people that want to see that and for
boxing if you want to get eyes on boxing
just makes
make the fights that people want to see
yeah right
like look what the ufc did it's not
anything necessarily special but there's
way too many belts in boxing oh my gosh
it's just too much
there's like how many different wbc wbo
[ __ ] nwo like there's literally
[ __ ]
hulk hogan's yeah dude [ __ ] uh and
also they don't make like even pacquiao
mayweather like they should have fought
years before they fought like you know
what i mean like
that's what's sick about the ufc too
it's like you get guys in their prime
fighting guys in their [ __ ] prime
where it's like this is the best
of the best at their best boxing it's
like maywe
mayweather fought pacquiao finally went
after he lost to marquez and was
slowing down a little bit and that's
whack bro he fought canelo when he was a
baby
yeah exactly and also made him like drop
a lot of weight and [ __ ] like
that's what i'm saying like that weird
rigged [ __ ] like the [ __ ] that
that's so whack there's just too many
like uh promotions
well that's wbo's one promotion ibo is
another
like there's all and it's it's like
imagine if bellator was trying to fight
one fc was trying to fight uh ufc like
it would be that type of
i think the biggest conversation with
with mayweather that i keep reading up
from when i'm watching all these videos
talk about mayweather and there's that
question that's asked who is the top
boxer in
the history of boxing right a lot of
these boxers don't choose mayweather
they don't choose him because he he was
very selective about who he got to fight
at what time right and so his last those
matches those great matches that he
fought saying that he beat everybody a
lot of these boxers disagree they're
like well
like like you said he specifically chose
to fight manny pacquiao after he was a
little bit washed up
he fought canelo when he just started
made him drop a lot of weight
so this is what haines mayweather's
record versus somebody like roy jones jr
he was down to scrap
everybody at any time exactly and also
you hear tyson specifically talk about
it when he said that like because i
think they say
mayweather's the best he's like no he's
like bro he's like julio cesar chavez
fought
he was like 90 and oh before he lost one
fight yeah like he had won 90
90 straight [ __ ] fights crazy
before he lost his first fight and and
then he was like and that
exactly that he was like and he fought
anyone at any time he was like bring
them all on
it didn't matter and it didn't matter
bro that dude got to 90
and oh that's crazy even though he lost
after that i don't give a [ __ ]
i didn't want 90 [ __ ] fights
with a and he had a brutal style like it
wasn't like he was
dancing like never got hit no chavez got
[ __ ] hit but he just hit you more
times and you [ __ ] died
he's [ __ ] and everybody so like yeah
how could you say
i mean you could say that mayweather's
the best defensive boxer i i i'll agree
with you there but like the best overall
boxer i don't think that mayweather is i
don't even know why anybody wants to
watch him fight logan paul
logan paul six three 220 pounds
mayweather's five
seven five eight and fifty pounds i
thought the fight got cancelled
no it's back up but they rescheduled it
because they like they didn't get enough
interest on that's probably honestly
they probably had something to do with
jake paul calling people out they're
probably trying to build it up
for that's exactly what they're doing
they're like let's get jake paul
fighting somebody now
the paul brothers are big now logan paul
fight now he just knocked somebody out
now let's get logan so mayweather the
stipulation is that mayweather can't be
above 190 pounds or something
mayweather can't or something like that
and then
uh logan paul can't be above a certain
way either
so but there's still going to be like a
30 or 40 pound weight difference but
there's like weird stipulations like
that
it's just [ __ ] stupid like what what
is the point of this i don't know it's
dumb it's something that's like watching
michael
jordan play basketball against me that's
what that's like yeah basically
yeah you're pretty terrible huh
yeah you know but at the same time it's
like why the [ __ ] are we paying money to
watch this
like this is going to be on pay-per-view
isn't it yeah probably and if
people are going to buy it yeah 100
percent i'm not going to buy i want to
highlight like
google i don't even remember i just
wanted to watch the highlights i just
need to see the highlight i don't need
to see anybody else in the undercard
they had frank mirror boxing he's
58 years old yeah he looked pretty good
he didn't look bad i watched the little
highlights he didn't look basically i
saw his highlights too he looked good
but he's also very [ __ ] old
yes you know and he'll also not be
fighting he also fought like a
guy with a pretty decent boxing record
yeah oh it's pretty interesting to see
what happens
you know what's so [ __ ] obnoxious and
it was that dude
in the locker room when tyrone
when tyron woodley was going over to
check the wraps or whatever uh and j
leon love was sitting there holding the
14 ounce gloves or 12 ounce gloves he
goes what you know about these it's like
he fights in four ounce gloves what are
you talking about right
he's like talking about the [ __ ] side
of his like more that's safer
yeah that's yeah you don't know nothing
about this i wish they would just like
one of these [ __ ] will come over to
mma real quick and just like just real
fast that's what tyron said tyrant said
in an interview with uh ariel helwani he
was like
hey i'll fight you in the boxing ring
but you gotta fight me in the cage
let's go yeah and he said it on a live j
leon love was on a live and he was like
yeah like these mma fights they'll [ __ ]
up boxers then why are you talking like
that
yeah right shut the [ __ ] up then you
know he would literally murder you there
would be no competition
what's crazy is that like there's
literally blue belts and like
purple belts and jiu jitsu gyms that are
like 18 years old that will [ __ ] these
guys
like all around the all around the world
yeah like before you even touch them
they're just going to
double egg you yeah it's over yeah
instantly
well it's just like it's part of this
culture now where it's like everybody
just wants to talk [ __ ] just to sell a
fight right
because there's all this speculation of
like when you
think of jake paul and we talked about
how he was like oh he has to fight a
boxer next
he's probably not he's probably going to
fight dylan dana's next isn't that crazy
you know who wants to fight stealing i
think so for sure he's going to beat him
there was a uh tyson fury's younger
brother yeah what's his name
uh something handsome [ __ ] though yeah
yeah it's something
true it's something cool like tyson fury
but like a little different yeah
infuriating fury his friends
he's coming they don't look alike at all
they have uh similar
boxing records because they both just
started pro they're around the same age
same size so he's like i think actually
i think he's a little smaller than jake
too but he's like
let's go if you want to test yourself i
have a similar box
though he's not gonna you're not gonna
fight because he knows if he if he gets
someone that's actually a little
competitive with him
the triller [ __ ] is over like what's the
gonna what's gonna be the appeal
yeah as soon as you lose that one fight
nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore but i think
after asgrin
he can't go down or at the same level
he's going to though
he's going to the fact that he even
fought asgrin is crazy the fact that he
thought nate robinson was crazy he's
yeah he's bro he's hand selecting all
these people but i'm saying like they're
gonna lose
like they're the the they're gonna lose
money if they're like okay you're gonna
find another guy that doesn't know
that's the thing
it's like people want to see him lose
yeah we're gonna pay to watch he's gonna
be a [ __ ] the more he's an [ __ ]
like that jay leon loves [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] to tyron woodley
he's i think he's all very calculated
he's doing all this [ __ ] to write
all the right people up and to get mma
uh media right now
they're they're kind of like yeah
they're talking about the ufc card
that's this weekend which is an amazing
fight card
but what's the heck jake paul what's the
headlines it's jake paul
then ufc 261 like and and that's the
story because all these ufc fighters
in the press conferences like hey what
do you think about jake paul why the
[ __ ] are they asking robert whittaker
after he had an amazing performance
about why he's going to fight he's the
kills what do you think about jake paul
he goes yeah
you know ben asked he's not known for
his hands yada yada but the fact that
he's even
asking robert whittaker that and then
robert whitaker says what he goes i'll
fight him
yeah you know what i mean like
everyone's like yo fight the guy of
course but he knows better bro he's not
gonna fight all these [ __ ] people
robert
would light his ass up i mean the crazy
thing is that he has to fight
uh people his size he hasn't fought a
person his size yet
everybody that he's fought is literally
20 to 30 pounds lighter than him yes
and a few inches shorter he's getting
away with it right yeah it's still gonna
happen because people are still gonna
want to
going to pay the fact that it got 1.5
millions
like views yeah like pay-per-view buys
that is
crazy and that [ __ ] was like 50 bucks
dude
that's so crazy yeah i don't know i i
don't see him going down after this
because i think they would lose money
of course in level of competition like
he has to fight somebody else that's
like even if it's dylan dennis i could
see that because of the heat but
it's still like i like his progression
has been like somewhat more real someone
more real i don't even want him to fight
tyron woodley because tyrone woodley is
still
five foot nine he's kind of older he's
older i want him
i don't have a i don't have i want him
to fight somebody his size yeah
that's it you see the videos of him
spawning mike perry you hear about the
mike perry hey mike perry wants to fight
him oh that's i feel like yeah let mike
perry fight so so
they did are you down with that they
released they released a video
or like a uh jake paul released a small
video after their sparring
where my parent was like hey bro good
[ __ ] dog like you [ __ ] me up like you
cracked me pretty good like
a [ __ ] you know just you know being a
cool guy and then uh jake paul posted
that saying like yeah
mike perry's like work so he's just
stirring the pot again like he knows
what he's doing doug
and then mike perry goes damn bro like
i'll be nice i was trying to be cool bro
like he's like i was just happy to be
there
and i was giving you some good rounds
and then he released his own clip
and he's like he's cracking the [ __ ] out
of jake paul of course
and and then he's just like damn bro
like now i'm [ __ ] mad
he's like man this [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] i was trying to be cool with him
and all these people were talking [ __ ]
on my social media and now i have to
talk about this [ __ ] yeah yeah he's like
man [ __ ] that he's like if you want to
fight let's fight
which is crap that would be interesting
which is great bro i hope they never cut
him
he could lose every fight please keep
him in the ufc because he's so goddamn
entertaining he's the blackest dude in
the ufc
four nigerian champions if yeah bro
[Laughter]
mike perry two is funny because mike
perry isn't a he isn't a precision
hitter
right now he's just a brawler so if he
could walk down jake paul that means
that he's going to have a lot of
he's going too he's going yeah they
fight he's going to but
you know and he could take it for sure
jake that would look better in this
fight though
like of course he's going to get better
i hate it like i
it hurts me to say this but i was like i
mean listen he has
the best boxing trainers all the money
in the world of course
he has a [ __ ] doing acro yoga
for him
yeah right like come on like this guy of
course if you if you can't get good at
boxing
when you have 24 hours out of the day
and millions of dollars to get better
i'd be [ __ ] surprised and he's been
doing this now what three five years
yeah so
he's he's pretty good he's he's he's a
good boxer for sure he's not you can't
say that he's bad at him
and how good is that [ __ ] acura yoga
[ __ ] doing that all the time
it's gonna be that much better i know
like you watch that [ __ ] you're like
come on bro just stretch
i actually didn't know what the [ __ ]
that was i didn't look it up i had to
look it up it's acrobatic yoga
yeah that's the [ __ ] you see couples
doing on instagram you know i mean
and they like [ __ ] after you yeah dude i
was just waiting for him to suck that
dude's door
like they're wearing like i was like
what are they gonna [ __ ] with they're
wearing like tiny itty bitty little
clothes and [ __ ] they're stretching each
other out like that's what you usually
see and then you see these guys doing
just like all right
trying to like spice up a marriage or
something yeah they're trying to spice
up the training dogs
but [ __ ] rob i was watching the ufc
fight instead
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] show and robert
whittaker dude
looks so good i've never seen that fool
just whoop someone's ass like one
two kick so nice dude there's gonna be
we did it multiple times
change levels with it too there's a
reason why he's like the number one
contender dude
fighting the the ranked number nine guy
and that's that's what you get and
shot supposed to be the wrestler he
couldn't take him down i was like dude
you have nothing for him
i was actually kind of impressed with i
mean look don't get me wrong whitaker
dominated his ass but gassim was kind of
like
i was just impressed with his his will
he's like the fact that he literally
never
like he was in it till the [ __ ]
end and he still kind of was landing a
little bit on whitaker whitaker was
definitely outlanding him
way more yeah but you look at whitaker's
face like he got through a little bit i
mean he hits hard
yeah [ __ ] hits hard and it's
hard look at look at uh sonya's face
yeah he's the only person that did the
artisana
so he's always game it's just he he
fights the same
a similar style in my personal opinion
like whitaker fights in and out
very low hands yeah you're not going to
do that to whitaker that's his game
right like if anything you've adapted
your style to look like his you're not
going to beat the dude and also he's
like naturally a little smaller too so
like a lot of his punches like
whitaker would just just get out of the
way yeah dude
he's very elusive he's kind of he's like
a brawling buff version
of [ __ ] wonderboy thompson dude yeah
right yeah and they fought each other
right and then thompson
beat whitaker that was at 170 when he
was cutting a bunch away
and that's the thing too it's like he's
so elusive super evasive his
jab is so fast so nice as a viewer i
didn't know when his dad was coming
also his takedowns bro he landed on some
nice likes like
[ __ ] tosses like his takedowns the
timing on him like he's just
all around he's getting better dude he's
adding that to his game because he knows
he's probably going to have to do that
him and izzy again are going to be not
is going to be a good [ __ ]
it might be different man who knows like
watching how how much better
robert whittaker got it might be a lot
more competitive yeah i hope so
just for the sake of the fight because
he's gonna he's probably gonna get the
title shot next
yeah and it's hard for me to think like
man it's gonna be competitive but
just because is he's so good but if
there's ever a guy to do it it's going
to be
who do you who do you guys have uh
kamara usman or do you have jorge
vidal my heart is with mazda
i really i like them both i like i like
guzman a lot
i re i love my uh mazda um i
it's just hard to bet against usman
because he's so dominant and so
like the right it's just when someone's
so good at wrestling it's hard to bet
against him because wrestling's like
seems to be the ultimate [ __ ]
also his striking has gotten so much
better his jab is nuts
it's a lot better it's cuckoo dude but
against mos vidal i don't i i
i'm sure the stand-up's going to be a
little more competitive but mazda is
so slick on his [ __ ] feet i i
i don't know make a pic what do you got
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go with hospital who
you going with
i was definitely uh i was like all in on
oozman
but as the days go on i'm starting to
lean heavier towards mazel
but i think it's just i think it's that
wishful thinking going on
i think i think usually is going to do
it i just think he he's just too
dominating bro like
usman is like the stereotypical
like championship mindset fighter and
jorge mossvidal
is like a risk taker he's like the
truest form of a risk taker
when it works it [ __ ] works dude you
know
but i just i think usman is just on a
different level
in all the areas and it just the overall
package
is just going to be tough to beat with
jorge masuda style
like he's gonna if for him to beat usman
he's gonna have to show something
completely different
yeah he's gonna have to show something
completely different i'm always gonna go
for
the reason why i find it very hard for
somebody to take out usman because usman
as a champion fights like he's a
contender
yeah that's so hungry yeah he's an
animal yeah he's a big weird thing when
you look at him you would you wouldn't
think he has a belt right but he has the
belt anytime he
experiences a little bit of adversity
you see some guys have shades of like
them like i don't say crumbling but you
see them like kind of uh waver a little
bit
with usman as soon as he experiences any
adversity
he just plops forward and just keeps
going and keeps going he's like the
[ __ ] terminator
that's why i like this fight though
because you have two guys mozville is
the same like
no one has ever really beat mon like
maslow's lost decisions
but no one's ever like mozzarella's
never been never got competitive in a
fight and and or
gotten just [ __ ] up or pieced up like
never and definitely will never broken
ever
opposed to broken ever so uh and based
off the last fight like even though
six days right but he stuffed a lot of
usman's
[ __ ] takedowns yeah a lot a lot
that's that's i think that was the part
that i was kind of shocked about it's
like yo
he's actually doing pretty decent and he
definitely gassed out obviously he
dropped like 20 pounds in six days which
is
crazy to me i don't even know how the
[ __ ] you do that right but
so he was pretty gas he was gassed out
after like the first run i mean trevor
whitman was calling it he goes
he has two or three of those rushes and
that's about it he was right yeah
he maybe did two more and then he had
nothing left yeah nothing yeah no
and they basically just stay stalled out
on the cage
yeah that was basically a fight like he
had him against the cage that was it
i mean so i think with the camp where
you're training for a guy and you're
working on specific moves on how to get
out of there like you're all
you're focused on obviously your cardio
is going to be better but you're focused
on what you have to do in the fight
against this particular dude
like i think it's going to be way more
competitive and i i think
mozart all can land on them and cut them
up everybody needs to train in a cage at
least once in their life
i think that or just in a ring because
it's so exhausting because when i was
training with savant we just had to do
the uh the first round was just me uh
shadow boxing with no punches right so
moving around and just defense
your boy was done that's it i was done
yeah got plantar fasciitis
that [ __ ] i was done i was like i can't
do this again
like that's rough bro how the [ __ ] do
people do this for [ __ ] 12 rounds and
it makes no sense and then imagine if
someone was chasing you the whole time
you're like [ __ ]
yeah and that's how he goes imagine if
somebody's in front of you and you have
to work around them he goes i want to
see you move i want to see you move
laterally side to side
i want you to go in and out i'm like
[ __ ] come on man you know it's my first
lesson
and it's so different when you're
aspiring against someone in open space
versus a small area oh yeah yeah so
different
you have to move a lot yeah a [ __ ] ton
dude and the chance of you getting
[ __ ] sucked in the face is a lot
higher yeah dude
and i think like that that small when i
was in that small ring i'm i'm like
you're there's no way that you're
probably not going to get cut off at
least a few times
oh for sure you have to learn how to use
those ropes and
defend it forces the inside fighting
yeah and also your movement your head
movement's got to be good angles have to
be good
yeah i mean it makes you way sharper i
mean even when we train like for the
boxing match i was actually glad we were
training in that little area because
when i was in the ring i felt like oh i
have plenty yeah you have so much place
to run
well he was like wow you only had back
and forth that's
it it was really hard to move around
somebody that little area and he had all
these little [ __ ] like nico and
alex just walking you down
like [ __ ] nico's big bro a big
[ __ ] bro he's he's i think he's
gonna fight in june
oh really he hits the [ __ ] car right
now that [ __ ] hits hard
he's leaning out that little
[ __ ] oh really what's he gonna
find out what wait
i think uh 185. damn he's like 200 right
now he was cutting from like 210.
i mean he could get a lot lighter than
that 185 he's still chubby
he thick boner though that kid he thinks
you got a big old head man i remember
hitting him a couple times and being
like [ __ ] this dude's head
hurt my hand you know like this guy al's
got that big ass dome down alex's head
doesn't even move you hit it and you're
just like it's just like the rocking
side
it just goes into his chin not even bro
like i've seen
he's like the thickest neck and traps
i've ever seen so if you hit him with
something it's just like
pink it's gonna be like what the [ __ ] it
is i find it very
hard to see him get knocked out because
his neck is so thick like his brain is
not gonna move he doesn't rattle no dude
there's a clip of me stepping off and
throwing an overhand right on him
and then david is hard too and i
connected har i felt my knuckles in the
side of his head yeah and i was like oh
my bad bro i was like i think i threw a
little heart he goes now you can hit me
in the head and i was like
i'm pretty sure i hit you with the head
that i looked at the video it's a direct
hit to his temple
and then he thought it didn't hit his
head wow he thought it hit his shoulder
i'm like dog i'm never gonna fight you
ever yeah i wonder if we threw a
basketball at alex's head like point
blank
if he was like looking that way and we
just throw the back of his head i wonder
if he would just like pink
man a [ __ ] burst [ __ ] on me dog he
looks around no that was a kettlebell
alex
that was a car bro [ __ ] dead in the
kettlebell the [ __ ]
that feels so thick people people don't
know and he's athletic too and he's fast
he thinks
he's surprisingly fast surprisingly
athletic i remember i was trying to time
him coming in and he would just get to
me and
he'd already be in my chest i wasn't
expecting it to be that i was like short
ass elbows in there
that's why you just gotta run bro just
run when in doubt yeah but in that small
ass [ __ ]
run literally even stepping to the side
he is the he's the whole
thing i was like yep and then he just
cast the right hand is there
would you fight jake paul uh you know i
was thinking about that the other day i
was like would i fight this dude
and i mean obviously if they're paying
me like obviously if i was getting paid
that kind of money
i got a door she needs school supplies
yeah for the money i would for sure
fight them you have to call out every
single school supplies she needs when
you connect it
lead pencil rulers
bow protractor child support
i've never seen such a hard right in my
life you can't disclose those earnings
though you can't disclose them because
they'll
they'll take the percentage yeah i would
he's way
bigger than me though that dude's he's
[ __ ]
big
bro probably like 46 right now oh [ __ ]
he's like 60 pounds heavier than you
yeah
he's a big boy it's up to you david it's
up to you
he's bigger than me too though how would
you wear it now
but this i weigh his i weigh 2 19
right now but this is 219 out of shape
yeah like
in shape i probably would be like 190
180 because
he's slims down to 190. yeah he's thick
he's a big dude yeah i'm not his size
i'm probably a good like if if i got in
fight shape i'm probably 20 30 pounds
less than him
yeah because you're both flabby dude i
guess bart has to do with them
bart would have to do it dude bart's
going to do it he's going to do it who's
going to save us you know dog there's a
video clip nobody he's
he's he's the joker bro that
[ __ ] he's the joker jake paul is
he's terrorizing the city he's chaos
right now he has to be found out
he's supposed to see the world burn yeah
this is not even a video clip of
jojitsukawa saying that he would box
logan paul this is before that he was
boxing oh yeah
he's i'll beat his ass i'm like joe i
don't know anymore
logan paul be training dude logan or
jake logan oh this is what he did the
japanese suicide forest thing oh
yeah joe's like how [ __ ] is that stuff i
was like i don't know anymore yeah it's
funny how everyone want to whoop their
ass and then they it like they can
actually kind of fight and was like [ __ ]
goddammit well like logan paul he seems
pretty likable now
compared to jake paul too yeah he seems
like
he's a little more down earth and he's
like the more likable brother of the two
and then jake paul just went full heal
yeah he just went you know what i'm
gonna be a
logan i'll tell you this though logan
looks substantially worse than jake at
boxing yeah like jake
is a lot better than logan yeah way
smoother i was shocked because i
i saw like logan paul's uh his bag work
boy stiff
yeah very weird cross very disengaged
cross very keep his hands up
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] so when you
look at jake jake looks like a boxer
yeah he looks smooth
i think it is if they if they box each
other i'm putting my money on jake
i think so oh yeah for sure yeah do you
think that's gonna happen next
no they're not gonna fight each other
jake and logan yeah no i don't think
their parents would allow it that's the
ultimate payday though
i think their manager is their dad or
something right i don't know i don't
think their parents would allow that
[ __ ]
that was that you want to talk about
pay-per-view buys though those two
boxing each other would sell so much
for sure because they just brother
versus brother those are two people that
everybody wants to see get knocked out
ultimate story line yeah they start
making out like the end of [ __ ]
bruno and [ __ ] because it doesn't it
doesn't matter who loses
everybody wins yeah everyone wins they
go cool one of these guys jake beat them
though
oh for sure jake is going to be it's
just so crazy how they leveraged all
this together
i like how they made this a thing now
and low-key
like this might be a hot take but
[ __ ] jake paul might be
you know the best youtube boxer the
biggest boxing fight in the game right
now like as far as like eyes and
exposure
oh yeah money like the i i'm still
like so flabbergasted that they sold the
1.5 million
yeah and that's like top 10 of all
pay-per-views ever
like it's they crack the top 10. i mean
it's a new audience yeah like
people who bought that fight aren't
people who watch boxing yeah no
it's the youtube audience they're the
ones who bought all that [ __ ] they're
trying to watch justin bieber in concert
bro
did you watching the performances i
heard they were terrible dude there was
so many
and there was it was really funny
because like pete davidson was like one
of the he's like
the comedian for the panel or whatever
and he goes into like jake paul's
locker room and he's like interviewing
them and apparently like
he's like yeah ben asker is a [ __ ]
loser like yeah you're gonna i'm rooting
for you or whatever and then he goes and
ben asker in this locker room
and then ben asks like hey man why did
you call me a loser just now
of course i don't give a [ __ ] he's like
hey man like what the [ __ ] is that about
like it's not really that cool
and then he was like oh well you know
you actually said something about me
earlier and he goes oh okay i'm sorry
and then they were like chopping it up
and he's like yeah i want you to win you
know
he's like going back and forth to the
locker room in the locker room like oh i
think you're going to win he's like no i
think you're going to win
a dumbass [ __ ] event dude just like
everything about it was like a [ __ ] show
i can't believe it was the worst
it was terrible it was it was a [ __ ]
hot mess but people
[ __ ] watched it which is so mindful
celebrity boxing has
is it's the new sport it's the hottest
thing
i was showing nick earlier a clip of a
bunch of youtubers
youtuber and tick tockers boxing each
other but there there is going to be
another event where tick-tockers versus
viners or something yes
youtubers and you know they have like
big-name tick-tockers
big youtube's gonna [ __ ] die bro
maybe man
it's possible so they did one recently
at you know tengoose
and um is that the real punchline
and there was a kid too he's a really
cool kid i met him on jk news a few
years ago this guy is super dope like i
like him a lot his name is uh
alex wasabi alex has been boxing for
quite a while sucks
and then yeah
trash i'm just kidding yeah but i'm not
but or am i
commit dude i said it okay there you go
all
right
so i was actually shocked right this is
not to knock on alex like
uh i saw him do pad work boy got fast
hands or whatever
and then you see him in this boxing
match and it looks nothing like his pad
work
i was a little shocked i'm like hey man
alex you got to probably switch up your
coaches
because this is this is not it like if
you've been boxing for damn in your
[ __ ]
three years and you look like that you
have gotten your money stolen from you
he got beat by a guy that boxes like
like a month or something like that
i mean he was substantially bigger than
him but this guy too if if it's true
that he's only been training for a month
to box he didn't look good but for a
month he looked great
so that just goes to show if he does
have real training he'll kill somebody
but
what it is though it's like when you
watch those guys spar or whatever
or fight or whatever you realize that
one person's on a different level of
intensity
and the other person is just like i'm
just here to box yeah yeah yeah yeah
the guy that had a month of boxing he's
ready to kill he was
getting after it yeah and people don't
really think about that [ __ ] when
when it comes time to to fight like when
you get someone that's really trying to
[ __ ] murder you
versus someone that's like oh yeah i'm
here to compete like it's a different
mindset
yeah because alex got tko with like a
body shot or something and so they were
doing some kind of battle royale version
where
they had you were boxing multiple people
in the same day
which is [ __ ] nuts it was like the og
someone's gonna [ __ ] die bro yeah
like like you get guys
you'll did grand prix dude that's what
it was you put like the the other event
the one with the ace family guy or
whatever the [ __ ] that event
they have guys on there that are only
boxing for like a month a couple months
and they're gonna fight another guy
who's been boxing for a couple
years like like this [ __ ] like the guy
alex wasabi boxing for three years
versus the guy that's only been boxing
one month
like on paper that's not very safe and
they're just
alex won his first match in there and he
i think he tko that guy
and then it's like the grand prix thing
where they find they have to fight the
next
exactly so he had a fight and it's like
there's there's no commission there
like it's it's a [ __ ] show yeah yeah
right and the ref is doing
absolutely nothing yeah they have
headgear and all that [ __ ] but like come
on man
like what are you guys doing like do it
right if you're gonna do it do it right
dude have you guys ever seen
on youtube i think it's called battle
for thermopylae have you guys ever seen
this
no so it's like it's basically grand
prix style it's like
five a group of but these guys are
russian cats these guys are yeah it's
all russian of course it's russian and
yeah but they're probably
get down they're pros and there's five
dudes five dudes and it's a skinny like
long ring so basically it's like from
probably the rings
like the ropes are from like here to
here and it's just long
so that's brawl or die that's it it's a
hallway literally
just uh immediate [ __ ] get down kicks
it's kickboxing i think they throw
elbows so it's muay thai
i don't know if they allow you to clinch
and stuff but there's one video of this
guy
that he literally takes out all five
dudes he's the first guy
he fights the first guy beats him up
second guy and i'm talking about like
beast like he's getting correct and he
[ __ ] up
all five he's on his own takes out five
[ __ ]
and it's like whole like gangster ass
get down each one of them get this dude
in the ufc immediately yeah he deserve
he deserves it speaking of guys that
should be in the ufc have you watched
street beefs
no that's where they fight like you
talking about mighty mouse that the
other mighty mouse the white guy with
the tattoos on his body
uh it might be they're like fighting in
hay yeah
it's like a ring but it's like a
makeshift hey named chino he's a
filipino dude that boxes
the best guy the best guy his name is uh
[ __ ] i don't totally forgot his name but
he represents shinigami
uh dojo and he wears a red ghee he's a
big fat dude big fat white dude
and he's been fighting on this promotion
all the time and his number one thing
like they always go to the guy and that
they're gonna who's gonna fight
he's like yo my name is alex i'm
fighting out of whittier california and
they go to this dude
and he goes fighting got a shinigami
dojo
shout out to my girl rachel and then he
just head kicks these [ __ ]
right yeah yeah yeah shout out to my
girl rachel that's his [ __ ] dude
hell yeah it's pretty ghetto dude it's
dope
they have titles like uh [ __ ] long
beach [ __ ] versus kkk leader
yeah yeah that's the [ __ ] that we want
to see that sounds like felony fights
yeah remember felony fights dog that's
wow see if it's
so wild if we could get rid of the
triller [ __ ] and then just put that on
the bigger stage i'd watch that
put on felony fights running back felony
fights telling the fight there was one
more there's
there's it's like a four on four
free-for-all one dude has nunchucks
another dude has like a kendo stick holy
[ __ ] one dude
and they just the guy that's announcing
it the ref the the [ __ ] herb dean of
the situation
and he's like about to announce he's
like oh you [ __ ] right he's all
like skinny ass white dude definitely
meth has been in his life yeah
and then right before he says fight he
goes this is ultimate gangster [ __ ] at
its finest
i guess it's like yeah that's fun
[ __ ] [ __ ] the best part of
street beefs is literally when they
introduce themselves yeah that's the
most part ridiculous
they're rachel you know rachel cause if
you see like a hood dudes they always
say like the same typical [ __ ] it's like
hey what's up
it's your boy alex out here man you know
what it is baby five four six nine
hopping seven six eight four seven
it's like i'm gonna call you like what's
up numbers bro where are you from it's
like you know what it is baby tree frogs
that's a tree shout out to tree frog it
is what it is and they can't scrap
yeah it's the worst idea ever man three
beefs there's there should be this old
promotion back in the day called
cops versus cons oh i remember i went to
i went to
yeah bro that [ __ ] used to be great you
went to an event
you were there too savannah cornerstone
this is when we first started
training like legit cops it was like bro
legit cops versus cons
well guys that used to be cops or were
cops like some of them were like used to
work in a prison
as prison guards and they're the felons
were guys that were in jail obviously
for who knows what the [ __ ] what yeah
but it was the guy uh
who's the guy from friday that he died
uh deebo
he was the announcer yeah was the
announcer bro that [ __ ] used to be
it was grungy dude like it was like in
that la not it wasn't the cost it was
like a
convention center or something it was it
was like it was hood as [ __ ] remember
people were like started off with
something you've got to establish it
if i almost got down with the crowd like
what the [ __ ]
we're just we're like 18 like what the
[ __ ] are we doing here bro
yeah it was hood as [ __ ] the fighting is
so crazy man
people don't know how crazy uh amateur
underground mma fights were
and it was so mismatched the first uh
amateur mma fight that i went to
i think i told this on the podcast
before but i'll tell you again there was
a dude
that literally looked like he hasn't
trained a day in his life
and there was another guy who looks like
he's all he does is train
right yeah they go into this [ __ ]
cage he comes in
picks up the [ __ ] slams him on
his neck done in like five seconds
and the guy gets up and the dude that
was training look pissed he's like the
[ __ ] is this
you know he was not happy about his win
i'm like what what what the [ __ ] were
you thinking why would you go in there
yeah right why would and you could tell
when the guy's warming up how bad he is
i'm like this guy's he can't be the guy
that's about to fight right now yeah
you'd be surprised every promotion that
we've
at least like not some of the higher
level pro shows
but some of the promotions that we've
been to to go coach and corner
you see like amateur wise you'll see
guys that just show up
with no corners and they'll go fight
and they're always crazy has their
subway
shirt on after they just got off the
shift bro
like there was one chick that was like
doing capoeira and [ __ ]
and i was like yo please don't fight and
guess what happens is that
they'll go fight and they'll ask one of
the other corner men like hey
like the promoter will come up to us and
be like
do me a favor and like corner this
person
what is your name yeah like [ __ ] man
like what the [ __ ]
i don't know this guy i probably this
guy probably sucks you know and he's
gonna fight some guy who is also
a professional and who is really there
to [ __ ] who's really about that life
and who's just trying to get some wins
on his record
you know and they're gonna fight and
guess what happens always a slaughter
and then there was times where we would
go to like a certain casino
indian reservation casino where like the
reason why they fight there is because
it's un
because it's illegal yeah it's illegal
to do but it's like on sacred ground so
like
no commission it's all good it's like a
weird technicality
we're in a [ __ ] casino we're in the
bathroom of like a sports
like coliseum actually not a costume
it's a gymnasium yo
we're in the [ __ ] bathroom stall some
guy's taking a [ __ ] we're warming up in
there
right what the [ __ ] let me tell you so
so
okay so heinrich's first pro fight
usually people go there to like kind of
get some experience because it's kind of
hard to get a pro fight if you don't
have any fights under your pro card yeah
so we go there
the guy says okay you have a fight but
here's the deal the guy you're gonna
fight heinrich
is gonna fight earlier in the day
amateur
but if he gets knocked out you're not
gonna have a fight
the [ __ ] and heinrich's like hunter's
like
he made weight already right he showed
up ready to fight
he sold tickets people came all the way
out there it was like two hour drive bro
to the middle of
but [ __ ] nowhere oh no it's the longest
day of our lives already
and we're sitting there like all right
[ __ ] it
the guy goes out and fights amateur so
he's gonna fight amateur earlier in the
night and then he's gonna fight heinrich
in a pro
what [ __ ] the [ __ ] is this exactly
exactly bro this isn't like 2014. you
know what i mean
like this wasn't that long ago yeah and
guess what happens
first 10 seconds gets obliterated the
guy heinrich was supposed to fight
murdered knocked the [ __ ] out where
we're like
this is not okay what the [ __ ]
so harry doesn't have a fight
didn't fight so we're like oh my god oh
my god
and then we go back i saw one guy
he just got knocked out and this this
company this promotion has a stable of
fighters
right but these fighters aren't really
fighters they're just some joe schmoe
that like hey you want to
make a couple hundred bucks
you just fight you don't really train
this guy comes out
he just got knocked out he's like [ __ ]
man i lost cause one dude
is on deck so on deck [ __ ]
and then he starts selling popcorn in
the crowd it's like what the [ __ ]
back to work idiot on deck means
that you're about to walk out the fight
just ended you're gonna
play your entrance you're gonna walk out
so you gotta be ready to go you have
your cup you have your bucket you have
your team you're walking out
the guy that's about to walk out that's
on deck goes [ __ ] i don't have a cup
the guy that just got ko'd comes out and
goes hey man you need a cup
hell no
let me get a cup let me get a cup pulls
a cup out of his [ __ ] dick right and
he goes there man
he goes thanks bro puts it in that guy
gets locked
damn the curse of the bad cup bro and
there's one more one more one guy fights
professional he's trying to he's trying
to get w's so he can make it to the big
show
right he's comes out of a big camp the
other guy comes out
he's one of the stable guys right he's
just there to show up to fight
he's wearing basketball shorts okay
the [ __ ] is going on yeah yeah yeah when
you go fight mma you can't
fight with anything with pockets so what
do they do
to fix this problem with the basketball
shoes this is what you do oh you just
get oh just wear some mma shorts find
someone with you no that's not what they
do
let me tell you they grabbed tape
yeah they taped up around his waist oh
my god
and then it gets even better dude they
start fighting
they have to keep stopping the fight
because this guy's cup keeps falling out
you know why he's the cup keeps falling
out of his pants because he's not
wearing compression shorts under his
basketball shorts
he's wearing hanes underwear you could
see the [ __ ] label bro
oh my god tidy whitey's with a gray band
yo
this dude cups keeps falling he keeps
falling out wow the
ref has to be like [ __ ] it it's over
like it happened like four times
the poor guy that did the fight camp
did everything the right way is just
like
wow because he trained all that barely
get to [ __ ] fight this dude
because the guy's cup keeps falling out
of his [ __ ] pants
wow is that [ __ ] crazy that is nuts
pure trash dude
it's it's wild bro that's why people
don't understand how bad some of these
amateur fights are dude
and there's a lot of people out there
that think that they could fight and
they
don't know how to i just showed dude did
you see the clip of the dude that walked
into the boxing gym
and was just talking mad [ __ ] to the
coach yes i did see that that guy looks
like he's been messed up
what an idiot bro that was bad man yeah
you got the [ __ ]
that dude had he just had hip surgery
six weeks ago the coach
oh they do [ __ ] them up yeah so if
you look at the coaching bro so if you
look at the beginning of the video the
coach is hobbling because he had hip
surgery
and he [ __ ] this guy his ass so bad
my boy's mentally ill dog that's what i
think when i see a guy walk into a gym
like that it's like oh yeah i can fight
he's probably like or drunk or something
yeah he was like you don't think i
[ __ ] researched you before i came
here what the [ __ ] do you think i am i'm
like yo this guy's
being mad aggressive and he goes what
you didn't have one of this he starts
like play fighting with him and you
could tell the
coach is so [ __ ] irritated so all
right cool cool cool he's like messing
around doing hand traps or whatever
and then he goes it's time to unload
yeah
one punch and then he wants to quit and
because he wants to quit the coach is
getting angrier
yeah no you didn't get the quit after
you were talking this mad [ __ ] let's go
[ __ ] your hands up yeah when he rushed
him he cracked him
i think with a hooker straight and sent
him literally across the whole [ __ ]
ring
it's crazy because you get guys that
come into gyms like that people are
crazy i don't understand
all the time people [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] people are crazy i don't i
don't get how
like you got to be something's got to be
off yeah you're like mentally
how could you not how could you be that
dumb you know i don't know man i punched
somebody in the head not too long ago
because
oh yeah yeah so you know there's a lot
of people
you guys were witnesses so i don't know
yeah yeah it seems like it's pretty
common though it's actually more
common than i thought it was going to be
well hey
every bro everybody thinks that yeah
yeah you deserved it i don't give a [ __ ]
i feel guilty at first i'll feel no
guilt no more no no it's over times past
everybody thinks they can fight forgot
about that assault everybody
self-defense yeah red welt red welt red
welt redwater
there were no circles there was a gray
area and
it was like leaning more towards like
assault you know
like self-defense and then assault and
then you were like on the spectrum like
yeah you were you were hanging out in
the middle but lean more
fight until the bell rings until the ref
pulls me off dude
super necessary dude that's what that
[ __ ] was that was super
that was very necessary that was the
first time i got that mad to hit
somebody though in a very very long time
years
maybe years yeah you're a piece of [ __ ]
what are you going to do
you're a terrible person yeah remember
when you were stuttering on this podcast
you're doing good see i know and you
told the story hey don't talk to me
hey don't be like oh oh you're not
sweating today yeah bro
very different if you want me
circumstances all
spicy and hot i'll get [ __ ] hot okay
[ __ ] talk to me like yeah yeah bro
you can get me mad i'm gonna start
sweating how about that
it was out of water bro come on act like
it was hot in here dude
you're doing fine right yeah i did it by
myself baby that was great i could i
could regulate my own and that was a
good story that was a good story cool
thanks man
i was actually while you were saying it
i was like wow he's actually pulling i
was i was picturing
everything like wow it was amazing hey
sometimes i tell stories good sometimes
i just [ __ ] get tired and i i wave
her off you know i mean what are you
going to do
sometimes i don't but all right
sometimes i don't third option starts
going into another story that goes
nowhere so the thing about eric andre is
right you guys know eric andre
hey bro back to two hours ago nick's in
the in the mirror practicing the story
okay we're gonna be talking all right
now hey man so people are stand-up
comedians what do you want me to do
okay i'm just the guy and i'm just here
you asked me to be here i'm just a guy
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] i have a podcast i
recorded with muriel and you guys will
hear the full story there but mario
caught me
uh so you know every now and then i'm
writing a if i think of a really funny
stand-up set
i'll write it in my phone but then i
don't know what it sounds like so i had
to say it out loud
right so i'd be doing that in the shower
and so
she caught me after i got out of the
shower i'm butt naked balls out
everything but i'm in the front of the
mirror
saying the set yeah and then i just hear
this door slightly open and she just
goes
what are you doing what are you doing
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] embarrassed as [ __ ] hey
but when you're in the zone you're in
the zone though
just getting harder as you're saying
this is fun again
the punch line hits and then my dick is
it pushed me further further away from
whoa what are you doing [ __ ] be gone
leave me alone i'm in my process
your artistic process yeah she [ __ ]
embarrassed the [ __ ] out of me though it
happens bro yeah that's [ __ ] cause i
because i get into this weird zone where
i
i'm trying to picture a crowd there and
then you just you just zone the [ __ ] out
and i'm working on this set and it
turned out the set wasn't that funny
so she didn't even hear a good joke so
that [ __ ] sucks you didn't get there
yet yeah you're gonna get it and then i
started telling the story about eric
andre
and she was like oh my god that's so
funny the joke was actually his joke
where did you hear that story it must
have been so good the first time i heard
it i could salvage nick's story
and i started telling it and then i was
like it still doesn't work that was the
joke
she said where is it going she brought
out her
yeah that was really weird just a fat
naked dude in front of a mirror and it's
a foggy mirror too i can't even see
myself trying to tell jokes all serious
yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
my cup kept on falling out she was all
weird oh my god dude that's hilarious it
was
so funny it was pretty [ __ ]
embarrassing man it didn't feel good but
when you're in the zone you're in the
zone dude right yeah like you're you're
focused on something and you're just
well she gets scared a lot because i i
talk to myself when i'm thinking of uh
[ __ ] stand-up [ __ ]
and so cause i'm mumbling it i'm like
blah blah blah this would be funny how
is the setup going to be here
it's the rhythms yeah and then so it's
just literally a crazy person just
walking around in circles in the house
just how does that sit with him
like that's gonna be pretty funny dude i
mean but you have to i do that too like
when i when i'm writing at the coffee
shop like but and i'll know i'll start
acting like faces out and stuff and then
i'll i'll
catch myself and i sometimes i see
people looking at me like yes because
it's literally like
just picture dude writing and then i
don't know where he's like
and it goes back to writing and like
who's like what this kid's like what the
[ __ ]
or that or they're thinking i'm like
that's some good [ __ ] my cousin that's
what i heard
one first stand up my [ __ ] cousin saw
me mumble to myself like that and this
is when we were like
going to church a lot so we believed in
you know all this possession [ __ ]
and all this spiritual [ __ ] oh he
thought you got the holy ghost and so
we're
it's like so we had a church in this
area called bradshaw and bradshaw is
like fields and [ __ ] and so at night
there's no lamps it's just your car
lights and you just drive down this like
farm town
and so we're he's driving me back to the
house and and i'm sitting there cause
i'm about to do
uh an open mic that night oh not that
i'm sorry
friday so saturday so the day the day
after because we had like a little a
church event on friday
and so i'm super [ __ ] nervous so all
i'm doing is working the set that i'm
about to do and this is like when i just
started standing [ __ ] fresh
i'm i'm a teenager too so i had a fake
id you know so
[Laughter]
and then my cousin looks over he goes
what are you doing and i'm like what
what am i doing he's like dude you're
[ __ ] scaring me stop that [ __ ] i'm
like what am i doing he goes you're
[ __ ] talking to yourself
oh and that's when i realized that when
i'm working these sets i just keep
saying [ __ ] out loud
now it's become i don't know when i do
it i just do it and she sees it all the
time so it freaks her out
but i've never explained it to her until
she caught me butt naked doing my m m
set
how relieved did she feel after you told
her she was like oh that's her comedy
well she [ __ ] talks to herself all
the time too and scarce
scares me yeah but then i think it was
just the butt naked thing that was just
very
it was very unsettling yeah it was just
an odd one before she just was like what
is she talking about
huh what are she talking about she's not
doing comedy so what's she talking about
i'm like you're not even doing comedy
you're [ __ ] friends
meetings okay she has a present she's
talking to her spirits no she wasn't
she doesn't uh i guess so what she told
me the source of her talking to herself
is that because she knows so many
languages she has a fear of messing up
when she speaks
but before she has a presentation or
something she likes to work out her
words before so she doesn't sound stupid
so it's her own version of stand up
exactly yeah but hers is mad boring
excel sheets
at least i'm [ __ ] maybe i should
start doing that i'll start practicing
my stories and [ __ ]
i'm going to re-workshop that eric andre
thing and be like yeah so like no please
don't do that
i'll work on it i was done that was work
on it you know if i ever go to hell
that moment's going to replay over and
over
infinity you must listen to nick's tell
stories
you only laugh for the first like five
minutes and you're like all right this
is too much yeah please stop
it's the story that never [ __ ] ends
dude what are you gonna do
that would be hell sometimes you got
some good stories like that what would
you think hell if you had to go to hell
like what
would you waiting for you to get to here
after making us wait for two hours
that's that's what would be hell that
would be my own
personal health that's it yeah yeah
that's probably whatever
okay okay now uh would you ever do stand
up
no i don't have to do it bro i've been
trying to get him to just stand you know
what he said to me when i was like
trying to get like when he was
seriously kind of thinking about doing
it i wasn't he was like oh wait wait
wait wait wait
i wasn't kind of thinking about you i
was never oh you know my thoughts you're
my [ __ ] you
literally you literally said i think i'm
gonna do it
yeah there was a period i would talk to
you and tiff i would talk to you
hey this is years ago when i first
started i was like bro you're funny you
would be i think you'd be a natural at
it
i was like and i would talk to you and
tiff and you're like you know what yeah
i think he's like
i think i might try that i remember
having that conversation a couple times
you know sometimes you say things
to get people to shut the [ __ ] up and
like just leave me alone no no no no no
no
and then he said this is the reason why
he didn't want to do it was he's like
you know what man like i don't want to
like
fall in like what if i just love it too
much and like i already got a lot of
things
hey this guy's full of [ __ ] bro i've
ever heard
he was like like i don't have time for
another thing that i love like i don't
know i love it too much
now you have to do it i'm not doing
those that is the cockiest thing i've
ever heard in my life
you are doing a set when this whole
thing
didn't say is the cockiest thing in life
so i didn't make it out
yeah that's the truth of the man's face
that's true you said that you did say
that
listen man like there's only one louis
ck i don't want to outside my hero
and i was like nick just say you're
scared it's okay
i can't i want to see you bomb on stage
right now my pistol is sweaty thinking
about it you honestly would be good
though
don't don't [ __ ] sweet talk me bro
this [ __ ] guy
i don't think about telling jokes to
people all the time
what would you like say right now you
had to do a set what would you what
would you talk about
where would you pull from i don't know
dude i really don't know i don't know
definitely
your parents your your family easy your
dad
[ __ ] hilarious okay wanted to get an
rv
you want to get an rv and just live like
on the road like [ __ ]
road warrior style you just want to
leave our family i don't think that's
very funny
that is hilarious yeah that actually is
funny not if you say it like that but it
is really fun
there's funny in that yeah you know he
did move to taiwan to escape our friends
i would love for you
to do stand up once
10 minutes set 10 minutes easier than
five live is hard
because you have to somehow tell a story
in five minutes and make those
punchlines quick
i've always liked ten minutes that's
over five five has been really hard
yeah yeah yeah it's just daunting in the
beginning like ten minutes you're like
[ __ ] i can't it's actually not as long
as you think but
ten minutes goes you're right ten
minutes is better because you have more
time to like they they can get to know
you a little bit
but i if we ever do the live if we ever
do this podcast live
you have to do standing and we're going
to be your openers
oh yes like honestly i'm just gonna sit
there and
laugh i honestly don't really like i
don't
i don't i couldn't i don't really see
myself doing like stand up like that
like i remember how serious he's getting
dude
i'm not being serious you said what
i got too many things that i like right
now and i don't have time for anything
so like what if i love it too much i
don't want to [ __ ] dedicate another
time my life i honestly don't even
remember saying that how can i be a
fighter
i do because i also probably out of
context because god likes to twitch no
no but also though i honestly i'm if i
died today which i'm [ __ ] praying for
uh
which i'm praying for to get out of this
[ __ ] conversation about me doing
stand up
if i ever like i don't have any like
interest in doing stand-up at all
i put on everything i love i like i
could die today
i don't feel like if you if you did it
one time not not to like pursue a career
but if you just did it just to try it
yeah and then you got some laughs i bet
you
i you would you'd be like [ __ ] that was
that was really really sick
like you would you would feel that and
be like because you're naturally you
like to make people laugh naturally
and that's what the standard is listen i
mean let me let me tell you this story
okay there was there was a guy that i
started
uh doing uh youtube videos with back in
the day right
he was somebody that wanted to be a
stand-up comic as well right i was doing
stand-up and then he was like oh i want
to try stand up too and he was actually
hitting the clubs a lot more frequently
than i was at the time
because i was doing youtube this is when
i was in sacramento he used to be in my
videos back in the day
right he wanted to do stand-up and he
really believed that he was really great
so i went to see one of his sets and he
started off with a joke he goes hey my
name is blah blah blah
i have a really small dick and i like to
call him maverick
you cannot do any worse than him that's
true you cannot do any worse than that
what does that mean though i don't know
exactly
and i remember when he did that set he
came after me he was like hey man what
did you think and i just said
fantastic yeah it was my favorite part
like it was an asian guy that opened up
with a small dick joke already nobody
gives so that's
so don't do that absolutely not he just
goes [ __ ]
he crosses it out what's funny oh yeah
this guy was so [ __ ] funny though
let me tell you this jackass right so he
i found out later on
that he was upset with me because i
didn't bring him to
la with with me as if it was my
responsibility there was something
[ __ ] or what he was like so years passed
by
and then he messages me on facebook
right
and he goes uh hey man i just wanted to
reach out to you i think it was my
birthday or something like happy
birthday or some [ __ ] that allowed him
to say this [ __ ] stupid ass thing
that he wrote to me
he goes yeah i see that you're still
doing well blah blah blah
i just wanted to message you saying like
yeah like to be honest with you i was
really pissed at you that you left to
l.a and you didn't bring me with you
and i'm like bro that is the sorriest
thing i've ever heard in my life what am
i your [ __ ] parent [ __ ] are you my
latchkey child you
dumb [ __ ] and so he writes this whole
diatribe like he was upset at me that i
didn't bring him
bring him with me i'm like bring you
with me you would you
moved to l.a i moved to l.a with
absolutely [ __ ] nothing
what are you talking about exactly
you're an adult
and so and so he writes this one thing
where he goes i just want to let you
know that in terms of like
comedy and being funny i don't think
that you're funnier than me what a
dick that's the worst part so check this
out he goes i don't he goes i don't
i don't think that you're actually
funnier than me it's just it's just
different right
all i did was write back to him after
reading this whole thing i was like
i am funnier than you which is why i'm
where i'm at and you're still a waiter
and you're like i hope you get married
so i get [ __ ] and then he comes back
later on
he comes back later on and he starts
writing this whole other diatribe about
like hey man
like uh he was like oh yeah i'm writing
the script right now blah blah blah like
i'm doing real he keeps updating me
about his successes i'm like bro
i still haven't heard about you yeah
shut the [ __ ] up just
do well so he just emails you his way
this started as a happy birthday
or something like that i think it was
like some kind of happy birthday or
something well you said happy birthday
to him no he said happy birthday to me
even oh he's like
by the way [ __ ] you and you're not funny
yeah like happy birthday
you're not i'm not funnier than you the
guy that opened up his joke with
hey i have a small dick and it's called
maverick it's like bro
you're the worst stand-up ever shut the
[ __ ] up i think he has potential rough
okay
yeah i think his potential but that was
such a weird bitter thing to send to me
because number one i was super
supportive of him
even when he wasn't good i i told people
to go watch his shows
to support him and everything else and
it was very odd for somebody to come and
attack me and i was like bro i will
never ever say anything good about you
ever again after that because he doesn't
know that i'm telling people like yo
when he's out there and
can you go watch his shows yeah like
he's he's trying to make it out there
and i don't know where this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
letter comes out of nowhere and then a
few years back again he goes yeah
i'm in talks with writing this tv show
and i'm like
how many times have i heard that from a
million people i haven't talked with
writing a [ __ ] tv show right
shut the [ __ ] up guy yeah yeah like
literally i
hope i pray that one day he gets hit by
a car
[ __ ] dude that's crazy that's that's
bitterness that's like bitterness and
jealousy hundred percent
and i what i wanted to tell them like
you should be jealous of people who
actually have real success
like what have i done really like
literally like this is just this is like
z level celebrity status
you should hate me when i'm actually
successful then maybe i'd understand
but what a slap in his [ __ ] face
because he's like [ __ ] i just wish i
could have a piece of what you have
but he couldn't though he was not good
and when he was trying to do youtube
videos it was a version of what i was
doing at the time which albeit when i
looked back and my stuff wasn't great
either
but his was terrible and he couldn't and
youtube was really easy to get behind
him enough
i'll show you guys the stuff later
youtube was going to put it in the clip
right here
to get popular off back in the day and
he still couldn't gather a following
even when i would plug
all of his [ __ ] oh wow so he was not
good this wasn't funny yeah
it was not funny maybe he got funnier
everybody has an ability to get funnier
after he gets work and maybe some other
people shat on him
but we'll see what happened but that was
such a weird thing to go through
it's like you can go ahead and try to
nurture somebody's town as much as you
want if they're not good they're just
not good
yeah i mean i can't like i can't sing
you know what i mean yeah i'm not gonna
be yeah i'll never be
not yet oh yeah you know you could tell
somebody that having online clientele
for fitness
is a really good idea three years ago
yeah yeah right but it's just
it's just gonna take all the way to a
pandemic and then they'll be like
maybe this might work out even though
they could have been way
more successful early on when i was
giving away
[ __ ] business coaching for [ __ ]
free but you know that person has the
tools now
you know before they didn't have the
tools but now oh no this person had the
tools
they had a dewalt set they had attackers
this person should be a carpenter now
yeah because i've been thinking about it
because he'd be building up excuses
it's so funny you bring that up like
there's this game that we played on jk
news today and it was about like
here it comes this is going to be a bad
story
[Applause]
this is the way it started i already
know because i'm thinking about it i was
like you know what
i'm getting real hot right now the
lights are getting
real bright and then the confidence that
i had
shot the [ __ ] because the hands the
hands the way you led into it i
i could tell there's no thought put into
this but go ahead go do it so uh that'll
be the podcast today guys thank you for
tuning in
i gotta go i gotta know this now so
there's eric andre skit right now don't
you [ __ ] do that i'm sure it's gonna
be good
oh yeah dude go [ __ ] yourself how about
that huh next time i'm gonna go to your
stand-up show and be like
this joke's gonna [ __ ] suck before he
says it and it works how well it goes
would be just
say the punchline before i say the joke
that'd be the worst
[ __ ] dude and i read all your notebooks
bro i know you're punchlines dog oh
that'd be [ __ ] up
this is dick's out there i know this
joke already
i just say it right before coconut water
but i know it's funny because we're
playing this [ __ ] game on jk
and bart pretty much gave me this card
that says oh the person that gives the
most excuses
and he gives it to me and i'm like [ __ ]
am i you're supposed to be like no
i don't give any excuses but i was like
yeah you're right give me that guy you
started breaking down
exactly i was like man that's true
though that's true so
you know what you're not the only person
that thinks that so you and bart can go
[ __ ] yourselves but you guys are right
hundred percent across the street you
just gotta apply yourself man that dude
you know what sometimes you just gotta
believe in yourself
you know why i get disappointed that's
what i'm trying to work this is why i
get disappointed in you right because
out of that group i'm the lazy [ __ ] and
you're
lazier than me wrong with you
you know sometimes it's just uh you got
to fight your own battles you know what
i mean and uh
you know beating yourself is the number
one thing at the end of the day
but that wraps up this episode guys what
a weird ending
podcast you can go ahead and find
patrick at patrick.t.riley on instagram
he's back in the standard game so get
ready to watch let's go
let's go baby and then nick is going to
open for him really soon
really soon yeah right and i'll be
opening up as well and then we're both
going to bomb together
we will bomb together i'll bomb by
myself thank you very much i don't need
you to bomb with me no we're gonna no no
we're gonna kamikaze sell ourselves
together
all racial and then you go racial don't
find me don't find me anymore okay
nick nick
the sweaty ass yeah at nick the ear you
could find him there babe you can change
my name to sweet tea baby oh
nick the sweet tea would be good sweet
sweet tea make the sweet tea
nah don't find me on nothing oh my god
genius brain podcast every thursday and
sundays we'll see y'all next time let's
go